[Музика]
так, том Nutella з подвійним
складанням для тих самих людей з
Китаю, щоб перемістити завзятий відеоролик Kalia, а
дитина з предметом чиказького університету Чикаго
на зоряному кораблі Scalia в даний час
переходить на Honda Michelle без HEPA
Bachelet Wattage не знає того
самого художника, який подає закуски, чиї
quali pastino the cart room which was
скромний e tomu Josh capital, щоб здати
Моурінью, щоб вийти на м'яч
[Музика]
привіт всім ласкаво просимо назад привіт наш дорогий
гість просто візьміть це в
послідовності  номер позначений як Rama W. Дана, вона,
яка чай із льодом, мене звуть Олена. Я
вчитель англійської мови, і у нас
тут урок англійської мови 5a Кава Йони Оро Хомейні
атомна брехня, тому перше завдання для
вас — подивитися на фотографії, так, і
ви зможете  подивіться ці бульбашки мовлення, у вас
на ваших столах є такі самі бульбашки мовлення, чи
можете ви придумати, що ці
люди можуть сказати, про що вони думають
, щоб ви могли просто записати, що
вони можуть сказати, так, а потім ви
поділитеся мною  з нами,
тож якщо ви подивитеся на цю дівчину, наприклад,
вона дивиться на свій гардероб і,
ймовірно, думає про те, що вона могла б
одягнути сьогодні правильно, а як щодо того чоловіка, який
він почуває себе дуже гарячим бокумачі, який я
дурний лайно з космосом з Робертою
відновлює крокомір Nam  перед шоу це
алюміній. О, GLIP, можливо, зробив би
момент, але це емаль на кожній клавіші
в продовженні, щоб повторити навіть віддалено
ритм Бокова, ви готові поділитися так
добре, я жив у цьому, без чого ви можете поділитися,
так що щодо дівчини для
наприклад, що я маю носити фантастично
так, щоб вона думала про погоду,
ймовірно, так, і вона намагається
підібрати щось зі свого гардеробу, так добре,
а як щодо чоловіка, я виглядаю добре,
я так втомлена, гаряча і гаряча, ми
бачимо це  пісня, і ми можемо сказати, що
на вулиці так спекотно,
так, так, ймовірно, чоловік мріє
про холодний лимонад або трохи холодної
води, і він дуже гарячий, добре, а як
щодо останнього, що ви думаєте
вона гаряча чи вона кучерява
так, вона дуже холодна, я думаю, так давайте
подивимося, яка у мене
погода, яка сьогодні погода, що я
одягну,
щоб дівчина думала про те, що їй
можна одягнути сьогодні, так, і вона думає
про погоду на вулиці, і якщо ми подивимося
на цій картинці, що він каже,
сьогодні кипляча вода, мені потрібно трохи холодної води,
добре, і чи можете ви прочитати останню для
мене, подивіться, так, яка кипляча спекотна погода вдень,
так, фантастика, чи можете ви прочитати
останню, я замерзаю, так холодно на
вулиці так  дуже добре, тож я пам'ятаю,
ти сказав мені, що ти пам'ятаєш ці
слова прямо кипляче, це було просто
забуто, не замерзло, deucey deucey:
g швейцар тепер є невеликий текст і
деякі слова відсутні, але
замість слів у нас є маленькі картинки і
це гарне заняття для нас, щоб правильно
переглянути погоду та словник погоди,
тому перш за все ми напишемо тему,
яка сьогодні тема, коли погода і
близько близько,
тому погода нам потрібна саме така
добре, якщо хочете, ви можете записати це
так, якщо ви не хочете цей рядок
, наша аудиторія має зрозуміти, про що
ми будемо говорити, так, так
що погода та одяг pehota audio
добре, тому, коли ви будете готові, просто дозвольте  я
знаю, що ми будемо читати текст
разом, тому я хочу, щоб ви
переглянули словниковий запас, спробуйте добре подумати,
і замість цих картинок ви
повинні сказати слова добре, тому ммм, що якщо
ви прочитаєте добре, я не хочу  виконувати свою
роботу, щоб ви могли читати, так, це літо
– найкраща погода у
Британії, жарко й сонячно,
іноді лише невеликий дощ, однак іноді може
бути прохолодно, що жарко, так, це
холодно, і дощ
khalida volou ahupuaa  вологий хороший протягом одного
-двох тижнів за раз добре, давайте зупинимося
тут,
як, ви продовжуєте, будь ласка,
британці люблять проводити багато часу на
вулиці, коли тепла
погода восени, погода стає холоднішою і чим
сильніше дме вітер або погода
так, також я  буде дощ дощ,
дощ іде більше, холодно
добре лейтенант, будь ласка, закінчіть
зима найхолодніша пора року у Великобританії
, снігу мало, завжди приємно,
коли починає сяяти весна,
сонячно, сонячно,
вибачте, і це  означає, що гарна погода
влітку майже знову повертається
знову добре, тому ви знаєте всі слова,
ваші відмінники добре, так що
ще раз давайте в прямому ефірі NASCAR Masonic
вирубує пагоду, тому, коли не буде сонячно,
Колима, лайно, я буду робити лайно  так
іде дощ або зараз іде дощ
kalim Abacha motor motor sherwani
здригається моя дитина
гаряча точка не йти жити не тверді горіхи в
холоді виживання
Avila hub надається мокрий після
ударів рініометра О з низькими рівнями лідер з
так двері цукор знову дощ  doc Я підкрадаюся -
вам,
звичайно, сніг і знову сонячно добре, ще
раз сезони
Літо десять літо Зима Орсон о, і це
не фантастична весна,
добре, ага,
ви не можете це побачити чітко, я не знаю
чому, але там написано, що немає такої речі,
як  погана погода це просто поганий
вибір одягу, що це означає, я
можу отримати його так, або ви можете якось описати це
якось пояснити якось
це вирішувати вам  Англійською або
українською, щоб ви могли використовувати власні слова
, щоб пояснити це, або ви можете
перекласти це вирішує вам, ви допоможете
нашій аудиторії зрозуміти добре
я думаю, але я думаю, що на мою думку, але
погода йде дощ, це дощ, але якщо у
вас є  дуже гарний дощовик
немає поганої погоди право Мохаммед
Будіа Пахінуі бародія капюшон dr.  Танака
набув форми над автомобілем Piranha e the
Shahada для попередньої колекції в кабіні від
парасольки Джакарта, додаток Python,
застосувати Stockton Pocono координує шум
так, що це означає, що тут
немає поганої погоди, а є лише поганий
вибір гарного одягу, і це  час
вивчити словниковий запас або переглянути деяке
відновлення, тому що я бачу, що ви
багато знаєте, так, ви можете побачити багато
фотографій, і у нас є слово Банк, який я
переглянув, чи можете ви прочитати
слова так, звичайно, джинси t-  сорочки
рукавиці рукавички наконечники шкарпетки колготки толстовка
пальто плащ шуба щоб
перевірити це добре легкість чоботи сорочки
кросівки кросівки рукавички купальники
плавки пуловер светр і
туфлі та взуття чи знаєте ви всі
слова
що зустрічають нові рукавиці замість
lukovitch e th tablet e  тож якщо ми
зазвичай носимо рукавиці взимку, а ми
носимо рукавички восени чи навесні з
рукавичок Iacobucci hakeem maluna Chuck's
Prabhas naisu y ki netic you tablet and
mittens to Ducie ta  pley — дуже теплі
рукавиці, ми зазвичай їх носимо взимку,
чи знаєте ви,
що це означає, так, чим відрізняються
чоботи Portis від Wellington, у них немає
ґудзика Chaya, і
вони називаються valleys, тому ви можете сказати, що
чоботи чіпляються, а лук Wellis хто
рухається  кожен орбітальний чоботи Веллінгтона добре
повинен взяти шубу Суба повинен
підійти до пальто піднебіння або плащ
тільки мій єпископ я придумав, що поставок
вона дає їй свою сором'язливість Ведра
Девід показати, що я не повинен отримати припливи дівчина
повинна знати, що, ймовірно, є  не
шкарпетки мм-хм ху-ді-ху знає мертвих так
, неможливо жити без балахона
ем окей куртка репортажна гітара кросівки
чи кросівки Кріссі Кріссі з ключового
купальника і плавки і
яка різниця так від Нік якщо кохання Кіп
любов ключ так  так хлопчики були
плавки, а жінки носять купальники правий
пуловер светр я думаю, зрозуміло, так
капелюх, куди ми кладемо футболку з головою,
футбол, добре, зараз ми перевіримо,
чи ми  Правильно чи ні так, щоб ви
могли побачити слова, які ви можете побачити на
фотографіях, і вони збігаються з створенням світових
друзів у Парижі, так,
це колготки чоловік, який задихається, сукня,
просочена, тепер джемпери показують тіло,
натягнуте або светр, светр, купальник,
плавки, туфлі, топ або куртка, кросівки
кросівки тільки ще раз для наших дітей,
щоб переглянути слова правильні шльопанці,
що це, дорогу назад В'єтнам
kthuman середовище до хліба рукавиці
бюджетні сатирика HK kedusha шаблон
резюме футболка футбольні джинси кидають
шорти semilla майже те саме, що
коротше dr.  Самуїл укорочує рукавички - це
ті, якими ми зазвичай були в Османах.
Це не дуже тепла капелюх, і, до
речі, у нас може бути багато різних типів
капелюхів, так, ми можемо носити літню
, осінню або зимову голову, яка
дуже тепла, так, так  це слово щойно з’явилося,
але ми можемо використовувати це слово в різних
контекстах так, плащ праворуч, жовта
шапочка з одним рум’янцем Кертіс добре, тож я сподіваюся, що ви
пам’ятаєте слова, і тепер настав
час трохи потренуватися так, у мене є кубики Lego,
і я думаю, що всі  любить це
робити або ти любив це, коли ти
був меншим,
так, у мене є чотири головні кубики, на яких написано
весна правильно осінь oisi Емма звати
літо Лето, а зима - це Емма, тож, що
ти маєш зробити, я дам тобі кубики, які
вони всі мають  слова є
різні предмети одягу на різних
блоках, тож у вас буде, наприклад, у вас
буде зима і осінь, і у вас
будуть весна і літо, все, що вам потрібно
зробити, це покласти ці кубики поверх
пір року, а потім ви зможете  Я розповім нам, чому
ви вирішили вибрати той чи інший
одяг, зрозуміло, так, так, у вас
є кубики Lego, і у вас є
пори року, і ми повинні підібрати
одяг, який ми зможемо носити або
взимку, чи влітку, чи навесні чи
що залишилося, осінь так, а також,
розповідаючи мені про одяг, можна
використовувати фрази коли холодно, наприклад
взимку я одягаю своє, а ти щось підбираєш,
а ти розповідаєш мені, що ти
зазвичай одягаєш так добре, тому я ми
збираюся робити це один за одним, щоб ви
могли випадковим чином підібрати один шматок Lego,
і ви можете покласти його кудись, а потім
ви скажете мені, де добре, я жив у
цьому молодці, щоб у вас була осінь мм-хм, чи
можете ви використати фразу  коли осінь
я одягаю светр я надягаю светр,
тому що холодно так, і ти хочеш
відчувати себе в теплі та затишку гарний як,
коли жарко мм-хм я не надягаю я
хотів би бачити, що все гаразд добре
коли настала весна, я надягаю тільки
плащ, тому що буває дощ, так, дощ а
багато і дощовик захистить вас
від дощу добре, коли йде сніг я взув
свої зимові чоботи мої зимові чоботи
мокрі буде мокрий холод і твої зимові
чоботи захистять тебе від цієї жахливої
одної погоди добра Ол
вія, а що ти маєш коли  він
чистий, я одягнув шарф, тому що він
недостатньо теплий, і я можу, тому що він
недостатньо теплий
що ти маєш,
коли жарко мм-хм,
я одягаю сорочку і сорочки, тому що
хочу піти з друзями на пляж
добре, а ти хочеш виглядати розумно, так, тому
ти одягаєш свою, тому що жарко, але ти
одягаєш сорочку  виглядати розумно так так
добре добре
коли настала весна я часто
надягаю штани, щоб не змусити ноги чекати що
саме дуже добре вибачте я забув
що таке основний купальник і глянець і
рукавички купальники займають Linux
плавки і об'єктивний купальник latif
cha  rter
gloves lokowitchki te команда Asumi
Innovation
Хтось може рукав tha Joushi tapley,
поки я не дам мого замовлення Привіт мама
Вершина я нервово Добре дякую вам так
багато
мм-хм. Ласкаво просимо добре, я можу отримати,
коли це перший, коли йде дощ, коли йде
дощ, коли  іде дощ,
можливо, трохи снігу мм-хм
я одягнув я одягнув шубу я одягнув
шубу так, дуже тепло, і ви будете
почувати себе дуже затишно і дуже тепло, одягаючи
свої шуби шуби tsuba Abdul
seducer tabla  шуби мм-хм, чому б
чоловікам також не носити шуби, я сподіваюся, що це не
природно, звичайно, ми не дружимо до відлуння,
тому ми повинні пам'ятати
про це, звичайно, коли на вулиці холодно, я
ношу пальто, щоб мені було тепло, звичайно, вам  Я
не виходжу на вулицю без пальто
взимку чи восени так, звичайно, добре
все ще я взяв рукавички добре,
тому що мені часто потрібні рукавички в холодну
погоду, щоб мої руки були добре, звичайно, так,
дуже добре, так що я думаю, що ми  покінчимо
з цим,
так, і це фраза, що ми нормальні
Використовуйте я одягаю щось, коли це
щось, що ви говорите про погоду,
наприклад, коли холодно, вони надягають
мій капелюх добре,
добре, зараз ми потренуємось трохи
більше, буде працювати зі словами, і у нас
є невелика гра, яка  дзвонив хто
має у мене є чи знаєте ви гру так,
це дуже легко у мене є набір різних
карток так, і все, що нам потрібно зробити, це
запитати, хто має і буде спокійним у мене
, хто має голову, наприклад, і ви
повинні  перевірте свої картки, якщо у вас
є зображення, ви кажете, що у мене є капелюх, так, і
ви задаєте питання добре, тому я
залишу кілька карт для себе, я буду грати
з вами, і у вас також буде кілька карт,
тому перше завдання - знайти
перша карта так,
то чи можеш ти переглянути, чи є у тебе
перша карта, у мене є спрага, добре,
добре, і якщо вони тобі подобаються, почніть, то
якщо у вас перша карта, що ви
скажете, у мене є перша карта, яка має
добре долини, закрита  Ключова
робота Бейлі хороша, хто має плащ, хто має
плащ, о, у мене є дощовик  у кого є
шльопанці у
мене є шльопанці, у кого є зимове пальто
зимове пальто, можливо, у мене є зимове пальто, воно
повинно бути дуже теплим, так мм-хм, хто має
джинси, у
мене є джинси, це добре, хто має
літнє плаття я чую, хто має літнє плаття  має
балахон толстовка толстовка я не поспішаю добре
хто має десерт я маю футболку, а
хто купальник
я чую здається ти, хто має сорочки
я маю сорочки професії снікерси кросівки
я маю кросівки хто має пуловер
мати пуловер хто що має  не
каже черевики о, це знову я мені знову пощастило у
мене є туфлі в кого зимова голова
у тебе зимова голова ні тому що
у мене є зимова шапка у кого є
остання листівка у мене є остання дівчина дякую
молодець  добре, давайте зробимо це дуже
швидко, ми знову попрацюємо зі
словами так, давайте просто прочитаємо
речення, і все, що вам потрібно зробити, це
підібрати правильну відповідь, правильний варіант, тож
давайте зробимо це дуже швидко добре, я дозволю вам
почніть з джинсів, ви можете носити сорочку,
сорочку, сорочку,
звичайно, сорочку  ра сукня
можна надіти пальто пальто поверх сукні
мм-хм коли холодно ти одягаєш піджак
добре коли тепло ти носиш
футболку футболка звичайно це часто слово
спортивний костюм спортивний костюм так,
тільки дівчата носять спідниці мм  -хм,
на пляжі ти, звичайно, можеш надіти кепку на голову, ти носиш плавки,
плавки, добре, добре, тепер давайте
зробимо це дуже швидко, тому я прочитаю
тобі першу, жарко та сонячно, я
збираюся вийти  грати з друзями,
і ти повинен знайти відповідного, тож що
ти одягнеш, щоб вийти з друзями,
коли спекотно, я збираюся вдягнути свою стару білу
футболку та сині шорти, тож коли
ми думатимемо, що робити  одяг ми можемо використовувати
я збираюся носити я збираюся влаштувати
о, так, вар'яте з клейкою стрічкою добре,
так давайте зробимо це
я буду імітувати на другому це круто
я збираюся піти в магазин я '  Я збираюся
вдягнути свій синій светр і сірі штани
, так чому б ні
гарна рожева сукня
і туфлі
бачиш добре, номер чотири йде дощ
я збираюся йти до школи і я
збираюся вдягнути своє пальто, червону шапку, шарф і
рукавиці, і останній, будь ласка, йде
сніг іди в парк я йду
одягнути моє пальто шарф і рукавиці червоного коропа ой
о так ми зараз перевіримо все добре
це вирішувати вам так я одягну деякі
люди одягнуть пальто без
рукавиць чи шарфа чи шкарпеток так а
хтось одягне зиму  пальто
і капелюх або, можливо, дві голови навіть так, тому
я думав, що це буде так,
так, так що йде сніг, тоді ви можете надіти
своє пальто червону шапку, шарф-мітенки,
все, що у вас є вдома,
так, а коли йде дощ, наприклад,
ви  збираєшся вдягнути свій жовтий плащ
і зелені чоботи, звичайно, якщо підеш
на вечірку, то одягнеш гарну
сукню праворуч, а коли буде прохолодно, і ти
підеш до магазину, ти можеш одягнути синій
светр і сірі штани, дуже добре,
тепер просто  дуже швидкий перегляд
теперішнього простого теперішнього continuo  us par
simple це дуже просто, тому що par
simple ми використовуємо, щоб говорити про минуле,
що є очевидним, а теперішнє просте
теперішнє безперервне ми звикли говорити
про сьогодення, але теперішнє просте ми говорили
про речі в цілому, які
вони повинні підштовхнути, що позначаються це,
ймовірно, рутина  eh, тепер безперервно,
нам потрібно говорити про речі, які
відбуваються в той момент,
коли Mucca li mochou Borden був Арісом, у вас
є Джехан Анна, яка показує, не рухайтеся,
о мій, я дуже в чомусь,
наприклад, впевнений, що я з'їла Джона і я була
впевнений, що я щось носив вчора лікар
машина проблема Індія слоган ми були
шоковані я з відбілювача, вони, мабуть,
знають, що я щось носив переконайтеся, що користувачі,
які я повинен сказати, Java Amukamara більше я
ношу я зазвичай ношу штани на роботу,
наприклад yo mo kawaru більш схильний
співведучий трето, тому човняр і
абрикос він пішов до Y mo, другий
геній, який він носить,
він зазвичай одягає щось на роботу, але
це мама Будди відновила Сема Роберта
їх собаку secundus qu  estion special on
the talk, е-а-а, добре, тож давайте спочатку прочитаємо,
а потім виконаємо завдання добре,
дозвольте мені швидко прочитати цю невелику історію
про дівчину, яка намагалася
підібрати найкращий одяг для латиноамериканки, чи можете ви почати,
будь ласка, це означає  завжди бери встає
о сьомій вона швидко встає
вона поспішає тому вона не чистить зуби
вона навіть не розуміє вона відкриває
шафу і швидко одягає свою
улюблену рожеву футболку і спідницю нарешті
вона сказала  нарешті вона готова, тому вона
повертає свою школу і відчиняє
вхідні двері, але є сюрприз, о ні
, дощ і холодно, я повинен
повернутися і переодягнутися, добре, давайте
зупинимося тут, я думаю, що все очевидно,
так, дівчата витратили багато  часу
шукала, що одягнути, і вона
хотіла одягнути свою красиву рожеву футболку, але
потім вона зрозуміла, що йшов добрий дощ,
Обама, вона відкриває, вона встає, вона
робить все, що у нього є шанс сьогодні,
вона шукає, девід забезпечує, що тепер
просто ми стояли  на нас дощ  це
Акалі, перець із Сарріса, мабуть, ні
, іде дощ, це добре, і хочеш, щоб
ти закінчив текст, щоб вона повернулася,
одягла светр і джинси, але вона
не може знайти свою парасольку, я
дійсно чекаю, нарешті, вона  знаходить свою
парасольку і мчить до школи, вона поспішає
добре, поруч є страва під назвою
російська, вона вже дуже запізнилася,
ммм-хм, вона стикається з Томом, але Том зовсім
не поспішає її привіт, просто привіт,
Том, поспішай ми спізнюємося в школу
Том  дивиться на неї в школі-сюрприз, але
сьогодні неділя ще один сюрприз для
неї так,
боже, сьогодні немає школи,
чудово, тоді я можу закінчити читати Гаррі
Поттера,
вона повертається додому, щоб насолодитися своїм
улюбленим днем
ня, так, добре, і нарешті ми  Ви
збираєтеся зробити цю невелику вправу, і ви
будете використовувати руки або ривок, так,
але гепард бу-бу-бу, щоб навчити
про це Пікассо, але проблема немає кореневого
перевороту в тому, що Слава зробити пастку розпочав
облем де кусати їх
Аля  Я можу почати давайте  дощ мокрий і
холодний на мені я вдягаю
чадору ой, морозно
він дуже зима зима охолоджений за
доктором вчора погода була сонячна і
спокійна я одягнув пару джинсів і
футболку, щоб вийти на вулицю або Манолі Чарльз
chewed over you супер команда ми працюємо
разом фантастично в наступну
так, команда мрії точно він завжди носить
носить з двигуном добре добре
це коли на вулиці мокро жує
наступну ми носимо літні сукні
сьогодні, оскільки погода спекотна  і сонечко
, ти такий розумний, ти знаєш все
добре номер шість номер шість я зазвичай
ношу свій шарф восени, коли вітер
і дощ, добре я ношу свої сандалі,
зараз кислота не гаряча ммм-хм так
і останнім він був  вчора холодно,
тому що холодно
це на сьогодні дуже дякую
за вашу чудову роботу, ваші відмінники,
і дуже дякую за вашу
увагу
, ось кінець уроку
до скорого побачення
[Музика]
tres la casa de dólar dos it to moi  впродовж
року вони цілують щасливого, як мене
ненавиджу так, вони цілують щасливого, як мене, ми
спілкувалися менше трохи більше кадрів
так, Куевас він розуміє, живе в
Шотландії створити продукт в SNSD
savolta флешбек О, Джастін Амаш
розслаблений, о, даллас, пост Мішка на
бичачий  диван це астрологія гроші,
справжні цифри у воді дотиків
у кооперативі дуже стильний
філософ котушка тепер він був твоє
інтерв'ю - Падуя
[Музика]
ти